buongiorno a tutti
mi è sempre piaciuto pensare alla
scienza gli scienziati come a coloro che
guardano al di là di un muro guardano al
di là di un muro per cercare risposte a
cui tutti noi tutti gli uomini sono
interessati interessate queste domande
cruciali per la nostra esistenza
discipline come la fisica la chimica la
biologia su su fino alla cosmologia si
occupano di domande di temi cruciali
come la vita lo spazio il tempo
la materia è appunto l'universo e dunque
davvero mi sorprende vedere come in
questi giorni in questi mesi per noi
uomini per noi persone comuni è molto
più facile riferirsi a profeti a
chiromanti a stregoni in genere
piuttosto che a filosofi o religiosi
e invece trascuriamo queste queste
persone così strategicamente piazzate
nella visione del mondo
dunque oggi a me spetta a provare a dare
voce agli scienziati
naturalmente gli scienziati essendo
meticolosi nel momento in cui gli
chiedessimo quale quando finirà il mondo
la prima cosa che ci restituirebbero non
è una risposta a un'altra domanda ci
chiederebbero definisci mi mondo
ecco che io parto ascoltando i cosmologi
i cosmologi direbbero il mondo
che cos'è l'universo il mondo è quello
spazio che l'uomo esplorato la esplorato
praticamente tutto è nato circa 13
miliardi di anni fa con questo
bellissimo nome io lo adoro non tanto
big bang ma atomo primordiale tutta la
vita era raggruppata tutto il rumore che
facciamo sulla terra e il rumore che fa
l'intero universo è raggruppato in un
piccolo seme di vita intensamente denso
e da lì esploso tutto il cosmologo ci
direbbe anche subito di non preoccuparci
la fine del mondo non è così vicina
almeno in in termini umani in termini di
homo sapiens infatti che sia un
espansione continua e un raffreddamento
che sia una riduzione di nuovo alla
chiusura fino a accartocciarsi sul
sul lato primordiale come vedete ci
vogliono altri miliardi di anni prima
che il mondo finisca dunque andiamo
avanti a cercare invece dove può esserci
la prossima fine dopo l'universo in una
sorta di gioco di scatole cinesi
scendiamo di un sottoinsieme
naturalmente incontriamo la nostra madre
terra
questo bellissimo pianeta ecco anche qua
qualche fisico potrebbe dire che la
terra è legata fondamentalmente al sole
perché quindi la fine della terra non è
altro che la fine del sole ora lo
sappiamo il sole non è altro che una
fornace nucleare nata a 4,5 miliardi di
anni fa quindi ai tempi enormi rispetto
alla nostra vita e questo tempo è quasi
a metà del serbatoio della fornace
nucleare che appunto si chiama sole
quindi anche in questo caso noi uomini
potremmo non preoccuparci di quello che
è la fine del sole e quindi del pianeta
terra
vedrete che piano piano scenderemo
sempre più nei sottoinsiemi e avremo
sempre problemi più grossi
però attenzione perché il pianeta terra
a uno spauracchio noi umani abbiamo
tutti una sfavore anche che si chiama
impatto meteoritico la possibilità che
il nostro pianeta venga impattato da un
cattivissimo meteorite ponga fine alla
vita di questa questo fantastico pianeta
io più che per parlarne un po per
scaramanzia ne ho portato una di
meteorite arriva da molto lontano arriva
da oltre giove da questo bellissimo
oggetto di ferro nichel e cobalto pesa
non avete idea quanto mi sono portato in
treno da milano gli ha fatto provare
l'ebrezza dell'alta velocità sul treno e
questo meteorite appunto mi è stato
prestato dal museo naz museo regionale
di scienze naturali un meteorite famoso
è piovuto appunto dai cieli di giove giù
giù fino alla terra all 11 gennaio del
1947 in siberia nonnetto qua un po come
portafortuna un po come scaramanzia
affinché questo evento meteoritico non
avvenga è difficilissimo da individuare
gli scienziati non sanno dirci quando
verrà se potrà avvenire
e chiaro che la probabilità è molto
bassa quindi anche in questo caso dopo
l'universo
col sole e il meteorite passiamo a un
tema più caldo è quello della vita la
vita è il mondo più importante per noi
vista dalla terra la vita
assomiglia a un qualcosa di misterioso
non a caso alla vita veniva dato un
significato almeno per la religione
quasi divino e per la filosofia invece
veniva dato un significato spirituale
perché le persone come noi
prima della scienza prima
dell'intervento di questi scienziati che
dissacrano tutto quello che toccano
appunto
noi crediamo che la vita sia qualcosa di
veramente unico anche perché
osservandolo da qua è veramente così
non ci sono altri pianeti almeno quelli
che abbiamo osservato in grado di
sostenere e supportare la vita tra gli
scienziati come al solito vanno a
cercare delle risposte dove nemmeno le
persone si facevano le domande ed ecco
che si scopre già nell'ottocento che
milioni miliardi di anni fa la nostra
terra era completamente diversa dalle
situazioni delle condizioni attuali
quello che vedete era un tipico esempio
di quello che poteva essere il
l'ambiente terrestre l'appunto 4
miliardi di anni fa
in questo ambiente terrestre vi erano
delle condizioni particolari in
particolare uno scienziato stan lee
miller poi premio nobel per la chimica
nel 53 riproduce quelle condizioni nel
suo laboratorio mette acido solforico
ammoniaca metano acqua h2o e co2 che non
è altro che anidride carbonica cioè
questi elementi semplice molecole
inorganiche prive di vita sotto alcune
condizioni quelle del brodo primordiale
della terra primordiale magicamente
diventano vita diventano si trasformano
da da particelle inanimate senza vita a
particelle vitali proprio nei giorni in
cui preparavo il ted
ho guardato questi cinque elementi e mi
è venuta un'idea sono uscito di casa
sono andato a fare la spesa
e guarda caso in un unico solo
supermercato non ho dovuto girare tutto
il mondo mi sono portato a casa
dell'acqua minerale h2o più co2
ho comprato dell'ammoniaca nh3 profumata
tra l'altro ho comprato dello
dell'idraulico facile così chiamato con
il giudice l'etichetta il 94 per cento
di acido solforico h2so4 non pensavo di
trovare il metano e invece poi
all'ultimo ho pensato il metano
campeggiano sono andato nella negli
scaffali dedicati al tempo libero avevo
trovato questa con bolletta di circa 4 c
a metano
insomma con euro 5 euro e 70 mi sono
portato a casa gli elementi base che
miller utilizzò per dimostrare
l'esistenza della vita mancava un
elemento che era quello dei fulmini
nell'atmosfera primordiale un semplice
accendigas da cucina poteva riprodurlo
questo atteggiamento un po dissacrante
che alla scienza e che anch'io mi sono
permesso oggi di proporvi in realtà ci
dice molto di più da un lato toni e del
mistero alla vita toglie qualcosa di
grosso perché è uno dice da semplici
elementi chimici l'ammoniaca e altri tre
elementi posso creare la vita dall'altro
però ci permette di guardare la vita in
un modo completamente nuovo un modo che
gli scienziati continuano a insistere a
dirci che è quello giusto
c'è una prospettiva una prospettiva
ambientale una prospettiva esterna alla
vita la vita si è creata non tanto
perché la vita in sé è fondamentalmente
qualcosa di misterioso non ha un'anima
non ha uno spirito non è un giorno di
vino è una cosa assolutamente fragile ed
è dovuta dall'interazione tra la matita
la materia che abbiamo appena visto
questi elementi e l'atmosfera in cui
viviamo e il clima in cui viviamo
allora tutti i climatologi ci dicono
continuano a dirci di trattare bene
questa è stato un signore perché come ci
è stato dato come la più fiera ci ha
donato la vita potrebbe anche togliere
c'era è per questo che viene posta
questa fa stati con f c'è il tempo
finale a poche centinaia di anni se
continueremo a sfruttare la terra in
questo modo
le sue risorse la sua materia prima il
suo cibo la terra a breve potrebbe
incanalarsi in un processo irreversibile
da cui non potremo più tornare indietro
destinando alla morte tutti gli esseri
viventi sulla terra
naturalmente questo è ancora un tempo in
cui possiamo riprenderci il nostro il
nostro pianeta e ripensarlo in modo
positivo per trasformarlo in qualcosa di
futuribile la parte che però mi
interessa di più di questo discorso
scendiamo continuiamo a scendere nei
mondi che gli scienziati ci disegnano
l'universo questo enorme e gigantesco
insieme di particelle che si dilata e
che forse un giorno ritornerà a
chiudersi la terra così fragile legata
al sole la vita questo dono misterioso
dell'appunto dell'interazione tra
l'atmosfera tra la biosfera e l'uomo e
la vita infine arriviamo al nostro mondo
quello che intimamente io sento più mio
e che da un lato viene minacciato dalla
cosa che mi piace di più dalle macchine
allora il nostro mondo è lo sappiamo
tutti all homo sapiens e homo sapiens è
quell'insieme di cultura e di conoscenze
di storia che ci caratterizza il nostro
cervello e la nostra interpretazione del
reale homo sapiens
come vedete da questa slide purtroppo ci
viene raccontato da charles darwin che
non è sempre esistito
non è il protagonista dell'universo e un
soffio nel tempo dell'universo 13
miliardi
lo vedete line altro contro i 2 miliardi
200 mila anni di storia dell'uomo quindi
a un non nulla nella storia
dell'universo lo è ancora di più
o ancora anche nella storia della vita
quattro miliardi e mezzo 200.000 anni
allora ci chiediamo è possibile che
l'uomo si possa estinguere è possibile
che questa razza in cui noi crediamo in
cui noi ci affidiamo in cambiamo di
essere i privilegiati possa estinguersi
guardando questo basta slide direi di sì
qualunque persona di buon senso direbbe
si sono estinti tutti quelli che ci
assomigliavano di più dal dalla
separazione delle antropomorfe cioè
dalle scimmie che sono preso la troviamo
di sinistra e gli ominidi che hanno
preso il ramo di destra
sono passati sette milioni di anni poi
siamo apparsi noi tutti noi li abbiamo
visti
estinguersi alcuni l'uomo abili l'uomo
di neanderthal
allora non è così strano pensare un
giorno il mondo l'universo la vita
potrebbe avanzare senza la nostra storia
qual è l'attacco che secondo me potrebbe
essere la minaccia principale non
secondo me ma anche secondo molte teorie
scientifiche e tecnologiche quello che
attacca direttamente il centro
nevralgico dell'uomo il suo cervello
noi siamo caratterizzati dal cervello
questo non segnano come chiamarle un
organo ma è molto di più è la cosa più
sofisticata che la natura in quattro
miliardi e mezzo ha prodotto siamo
partiti dal brodo primordiale siamo
arrivati su su incastra complessità
organizzata che il nostro cervello che
ci fa interpretare la realtà in modo
assolutamente originale
ecco se il cervello si parla se il
cervello e non certo le capacità
predatorie le nostre dimensioni ci
permettono di essere i dominatori del
pianeta terra
se cominciamo a parlare l'intelligenza
artificiale io credo che li dobbiamo
guardare le minacce più grosse cioè
quelli che vengono chiamati banalmente
robot potrebbero arrivare se non farci
estinguere forse come abbiamo fatto noi
con altre razze nel passato ma almeno
rubarci la scena dal dalla terra dal
nostro pianeta
com'è possibile dire questo io ho
provato a raccogliere un po di dati e
fare delle analogie che funzionano
sempre in alto vedete lo sviluppo
biologico della vita in basso vedete lo
sviluppo tecnologico delle macchine
allora incredibile ma queste due curve
si assomigliano tantissimo adesso
dobbiamo solo capire dove siamo
posizionati e con che velocità
avanzeranno le tecnologie perché la vita
lo sappiamo è nata appunto 4 miliardi di
anni fa
la cosa più alta lo vedete in quel
pallino in fondo alla parte che cresce
lentamente la cosa più raffinata che è
riuscita a credere a creare la biologia
e questa bruttissima o bellissima
dipende dai punti di vista
medusa essere in 4 miliardi avevano
intelligenza limitatissima eppure per 4
miliardi e mezzo questo è il frutto
della dell'evoluzione a un certo punto
ho detto proviamo a vedere cosa è
successo nella tecnologia 300.000 anni
di tecnologia quella che va dalla
scoperta di
gli utensili in pietra su su su su fino
alla rivoluzione industriale
alla fine hanno prodotto non essere semi
intelligente mi piace chiamarlo così è
una valvola elettronica inventata nel
1903 e con cui l'uomo ha costruito le
prime intelligenze artificiali
i primi computer i primi cervelli
elettronici siamo naturalmente alla metà
del novecento la curva di crescita
dell'intelligenza della complessità
degli organismi o degli organi
automatici è molto bassa però è successo
per qualcosa di strano se si è
cominciato a prendere una rampa strana
sia nel mondo animale nel mondo
biologico sono arrivati questi trilobiti
nell esplosione cambriana così chiamata
la vita si è moltiplicata di 100 volte
molte più specie soprattutto più
organizzati trilobiti rivedete sono
diversi dalle meduse hanno già un
aspetto di un qualcosa che esplora il
mondo naturalmente siamo sempre nei mari
primordiali e sotto invece l'amatissimo
microprocessore scoperto nel 1970 il
dispositivo che ha permesso veramente di
persona niente che assomiglia un po un
trilobite che ha permesso di partire con
l'ira elettroniche ci troviamo
all'inizio della rampa della folla che
viene chiamata singolarità tecnologica
quella che ci spingerà in pochi anni lo
vedrete in mondi che prima non pensavamo
nemmeno esistere
permettetemi di andare avanti
velocemente la stessa cosa si può dire
quando dei sensori quelli che noi oggi
chiamiamo occhi e orecchie hanno
migliorato tantissimo gli esseri viventi
siamo nel metà circa 250 milioni di anni
da dove siamo noi oggi è la tecnologia
allo stesso modo ha seguito la stessa
cosa
ha cominciato a dotare di sensori i
fotodiodi e dei pannelli fotovoltaici
questi piccoli robottini io sono
particolarmente affezionato li ho visti
per la prima volta questi ragnetti al
museo nazionale della scienza tecnologia
che per oggi me li ha prestati cosa sono
questi si chiamano fotoni io li lumino e
loro seguono la luce vanno a cercarsi
l'energia per alimentarsi continuare a
sopravvivere
ora da lì forse non apprezzerete
tantissimo ma vi assicuro che
impressionante
che hanno un intelligenza piccola ma
pure io vado a illuminare questi
ragnetti e loro seguono la luce è la
prima volta che un essere artificiale è
in grado di gestire le energie
ambientali e in grado di prendere delle
decisioni per sopravvivere
e chiaro che non sono stupido lo chiedo
che può essere poco immaginate un
rispetto al nostro cervello
però però anche che non pensiate che
quell essere che vedete sopra
corrispondente a quello che vi ho appena
mostrato non parlasse certo di platone o
di aristotele andava a cercarsi il cibo
esattamente come fa questo quindi la
metafora continua e passiamo a quello
dopo
in pochissimo tempo gli organi viventi
biologici diventano dinosauri veri e
propri predatori in grado di conquistare
e dominare l'intero pianeta
allo stesso modo oggi ci troviamo con
questi dinosauri un po ridicoli che sono
i robot quelli che oggi sono sulla luna
a lavorare al posto nostro e sempre di
più arriveranno in mezzo a noi nei
prossimi anni
e chiaro che vedendoli i robot fanno
ancora un po ridere ma perché siamo in
una fase di crescita talmente veloce che
tutto quello che viene creato ci sembra
vecchio pensate con che velocità i
lucertoloni sono stati sostituiti dal
dal dinosauri il dinosauro da altre
specie e poi fino arrivare su al
all'uomo all intelligenza superiore che
fino ad oggi ha dominato il nostro
pianeta li vedete nell'ultimo passaggio
e la biologia si chiama homo sapiens
si chiama albert einstein mio eroe e
nella tecnologia si chiama umanoide
robot chiamatelo come volete
impareremo presto il loro nome la cosa
incredibile che questo passaggio da quel
robot giallo al umma noi dal post umano
sarà in pochissimo tempo quanto tempo lo
dico un po di emozione saranno meno di
20 anni nel 2029 saremo circondati non
con cattiveria da questi esseri h più
homo sapiens potenziato lo dice la
teoria appunto della singolarità
tecnologica questi uomini o umanoidi
questa intelligenza artificiale
ci aiuteranno a migliorarci a passare da
uno stato di evoluzione ad un altro
perché c'è chi pensa anche che non sia
proprio così non ci sia un ramo di
produzione di una nuova specie quella
post umana meccanica ma ci sia
un'integrazione tra il silicio il
carbonio cioè tra la vita tecnologica e
la vita biologica e che quindi noi
passeremo a una miglior vita di
condizioni di vita più lunga più
potenziate celebralmente fisicamente nel
2045 quando potremmo addirittura
scegliere se continuare a vivere in
eterno e chiaro che anche in me sono
certo che anche in voi se sentite per la
prima volta questi temi ci sono due
atteggiamenti uno di paura perché da un
lato c'è la voglia della tradizione di
mantenere le cose così come stanno
perché ci hanno permesso di arrivare
fino qua dall'altro invece di
grandissima eccitazione l'innovazione
così chiamata io ho voglia moltissima
voglia di vedere apparire questi esseri
che questi esseri per poter condividere
con loro tutto quello che fino adesso ad
oggi praticamente abbiamo vissuto da
soli o quasi da soli dunque e concludo
io spero che nel 2045 felix organizzi un
altro the jicks a firenze che ci sia una
macchina a parlare al posto mio io sarò
lì in mezzo a voi e sarà ad applaudirlo
come spero che sia anche per voi
grazie